pense que nous devons toujours à
l'assemblée nationale essayer de faire
progresser ce droit des malades cette
capacité à pouvoir
apporter de la dignité du triple moment
passé l'équilibré n'est pas simple et
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous avons choisi
avec un parlementaire de droite reconnu
pour les travaux qu'il a fait même si
nous pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin
il a des espaces et mais il a été très
largement très largement mardi en fin
d'après midi parce qu'il représente une
avancée et que sur ce sujet les avancées
doivent se faire pas à pas et essayer de
réunir et moi je suis très fier que sur
ce texte nous n'aurions pas essayer
d'opposer mais essayez de réunion est ce
que vous pensez qu'avec la loi qui a été
votée il n'y aura plus de quatre
secondes je ne peux pas le garantir je
ne peux pas le garantir et donc il
faudra très sérieux que la loi de
garantie n'est d'ailleurs jean leonetti
et alain claeys disent eux-mêmes que
cette loi appellera très certainement
demain de nouveaux débats et donc une
nouvelle loi compte tenu de la façon
niveau législateur cesser les limites
des législateurs sur ces questions qui
touchent aux progrès d'ailleurs de la
médecine qui touchent à des débats de
société qui touche à des débats
philosophiques qui touche et donc le
législateur doit faire attention sur ces
questions a créé du progrès et en même
temps a toujours essayé d'union